it's time for the lawn gene conosco a
television journal of the important
issues of the hour brought to you every
monday wednesday and fridays a
presentation of the lawn gene wit nor
watch company maker of lon gene the
world's most honored watch and wit nor
distinguished companion to the world
honored lon gene good evening this is
frank night may I introduce our
co-editors for this edition of their own
gene chrono scope from the CBS
television news staff Larry Mercer and
Ned calmar our distinguished guest for
this evening is basil O'Connor president
of the National Foundation for infantile
paralysis in spite of all the miraculous
advances made in medical science during
our lifetimes there's still one epidemic
uncontrollable disease that's increasing
every year and this year unfortunately
is no exception despite all our efforts
polio is affecting more people this
summer than ever before Mr O'Connor
earlier this year we were told that we
might be on the verge of victory over
polio through the new saw vaccine what
has happened well we still may be on the
verge of victory of course this last
summer we put on the one great field
trial of a vaccine has ever been had in
the history of the world we gave the
vaccine to four hundred and forty five
thousand children we gave another
200,000 or what we call a an innocuous
substance what we call a placebo and in
217 places throughout the country we
tested out the validity of what we call
the salk vaccine some people didn't know
they were what they were getting that
the half the group at the placebo study
the control study half them that vaccine
half got something else but nobody knows
we have the key to that when will the
results be known well that's it right
now of course we're going through the
evaluation period and that's a long hard
a laborious job and I don't see how we
can possibly know that until the
epidemic season is over say around of
them the first and it will take time
after that
and we can't possibly know the results
until these till December 31st maybe not
then we do mr. O'Connor is it possible
that some of these people who are
getting polio now are getting it from
the vaccine that could be possible but
we have no reason to believe it and in
any event in the placebo study we
couldn't tell because until you break
the key and find out who got the vaccine
who got the placebo you don't know but
so far the safety of this vaccine has
been really ruled out is there a sore
butt available now sir no you see this
vaccine is simply now in the trial state
is not commercially available can't be
bought no it can't be bought and if it's
determined to be effective of course
well then the manufacturing houses
undoubtedly will produce it to the
extent they can but how's the efficacy
of this Jonas Salk vaccine actually been
proved but I think in the laboratory or
rather experimental wise not the
laboratory it has in the laboratory
monkeys but in human beings experimental
eyes it has been demonstrated that this
vaccine will raise the antibody content
of the blood sufficient which should be
sufficient to protect against Paulie
paralytic polio and it's encountered the
natural stage but until that happens you
see what we've done now we've given the
vaccine and now we're waiting for the
epidemics to come in those 217 areas so
these children will come in contact with
the disease in the natural condition now
if they if the vaccine is effective it
should prevent them from getting paralee
palio paralytic polio that's what we
want to find out well you said 217
various areas now where are the Aaron
body cases coming up now sir most cases
now this year we are in four spots so
far rather curiously California Texas
Florida and Hawaii believe it not
Hawaii's having quite a quite a
relatively large insolence I think my
memory is right I hope they're having on
they have 137 cases now as against a
five year average something like Sergio
case of whether disease well we visit
associated with us so we don't know
anymore it is yes we get our peaks in
july and august and sep tember but now
it Lots places in this country it's in
Deming I don't ask me which places
because nobody likes to have that set of
their place but but it runs pretty well
through the year we'll have it from
January first to know this number 35
kinda how do you account the fact that
children get it more often in the summer
when we think of them as getting more
Sun and more exercises and being
generally healthier well course you know
i'm a lame and i'm not a scientist so I
all I can tell you is what somebody else
tells me I think it's probably do
primary to the fact that they make new
contacts they go from a place where
they've had no immunity and they go to
another place and get into other clouds
where the disease is prevalent and they
they they encounter it that way they get
into new groupings of children and I
think it's probably movement in the
summer plus getting over tired /
exercising and then neglect not watching
their their headaches and their clothes
and so forth well is it wise do you
think to keep a child isolated during
the summer or is it better to expose
them to these new context that they
normally would meet at camps and in
pools well I certainly would certainly
wouldn't expose them to the disease
itself but I don't think one can go so
far as to keep their child isolated and
I think we really don't know we do know
that it doesn't come from water we know
it doesn't have them pools or milk to
things like that we know it's contact
disease and therefore I suppose the more
contacts you make in the new of the
contacts the more you increase the
likelihood but Emerson once you know
remember say an essay saying that you
can't run away from anything so that but
I think it is a good idea to see that
they don't get tired too tired call the
doctor the minute they show any symptoms
was opposing ones child develops a sore
throat during the summer what should the
parent do about it call the way did he
go and ask for a shot of salt vaccine no
they won't get it because not available
but the thing they should do is call the
doctor and then first make sure it is
polio not get too excited about it
sometimes it is and sometimes it is if
there's a large family mr. O'Connor what
will the others immediately be exposed
don't want any doubt about that if you
have one case the family the others in
the family will all
had that virus now they may not have
paralytic polio but they will have had
the virus Mr O'Connor should do you
immediately take the child and send it
away or send the other children away to
their grandmothers or two friends to get
them away from the child which has polio
i I don't I shouldn't think so I'm not a
doctor or scientist but I shouldn't
think so i figured with all depend on
what the family doctor feels is their
condition our seriously thinks we're
going to be paralytic polio if they're
going to be paralytic polio the hospital
is undoubtedly the best place for them
in some cases not all cases if they're
if they look like they're going to be an
abortive case why they just as well as
homes are where else provided they put
to bed and get over the early symptoms
well mr. O'Connor you are talking about
the salt vaccine this summer and last
year there was tremendous run on what
was called a gamma globulin and so now
the United States Public Health Service
I understand doesn't feel that gamma
globulin is effective anymore no no they
never said the public health never said
that no what happened was a committee
that was set up by the Public Health
Service made a report out of Atlanta
that said the use of gamma globulin
family contacts was no good and we
always said that then I was any
basically evening was any good and then
they said that the use of gamma globulin
in mass prophylaxis giving it to in the
mass all they said was that as it was
used last summer they couldn't draw a
conclusion whether it was good or not
but the fact remains that be the only
scientific context the control test made
by dr. Hammond and 51 and 52 which we
paid for the National Foundation that
scientific tests still proves that gamma
goblin given at the proper time before
the virus gets into the host and the
proper kind of gamma clobberin will
protect from originally for five weeks
but his recent work in the laboratory
shows that will protect for eight weeks
so the only scientific evidence that
exists shows that gamma glawen is as
effective as it ever was and will
protect temporarily against paralytic
polio now it is available to public
health may inhabit there will be a
demand for this summer and it should and
it will be used but all that report said
was that used in the contact method you
remember I've just said that once you
have a case in the family they've all
got the virus will obviously giving them
gamma
men won't help the men in and that was
well known and why it was ever used that
way we never do I understand sir that
you cannot get a an occupation or a
vaccination from the Salk vaccine now
what you still can get an inoculation of
gamma globulin that's right there's
about two million shots of gamma Glavine
available in this country and that's
been distributed among the public health
men not all of it but it's available as
half of its gone out or is available the
other half will be available when the
public health men wanted and they could
use it much more liberally this year
that is they don't have to do just great
masses they can use it in groups above
the family group for instance if they
have a school that there's a couple of
cases and they want to they can give it
to the rest of the children at school
that they couldn't do last summer so it
could be used much better much more
quickly this summer and they have it and
is the extent they have it to be sure
still in limited supply there will be a
demand fitness should be used they've
used a lot of it in florida and i think
the reports out of florida are going to
be very encouraging as the use of care
McLoughlin when it is used in the proper
time and in the proper way tell us mr.
O'Connor how did you how did you get
into this work in the first place and
again was the President Roosevelt we
will all pop as we went down a warm
springs in 1924 that's the first time he
went when he got polio you may
definitely attracted it he got polluted
21 then he could interest in Warm
Springs they had a pool there with hot
water and he went down route to play so
and I went down with him and then he
started to take it over and make it a
place available to other people then he
was elected governor 1928 he simply said
to me will you take over night to go as
you told Mr O'Connor it seems that the
National Foundation is going to run
another drive for funds but i remember
back in january you raised 55 million
dollars which was the greatest some ever
raised in history of the foundation
that's why do you need more money well
you see in January asked for 75 million
dollars for our big four programs now
one of our big programs is patient care
another one is polio prevention for
polio prevention this year we needed 26
and a half million dollars over and
above our usual needs that's what ran us
from 50 to 75 million now our patient
patient a program that's where we give
aid to those who need it financially
runs for approximately 29 million
dollars
unless and professional education
scientific research program runs 19 if
you'll add those up you'll get 75 now we
did not get 20 of that 75 and if we do
not have it we can't carry out those
programs now see what that would mean
inpatient aid that would mean that we
cannot give the patient aid that we
always have given for 16 years you're
giving patient aid to people who have
already incurred Julio that's right how
long is that patient late last well it
can last anyway from 30 days to an
indefinite period of time at three four
five six or ten years really depending
on the case as a matter of fact we spend
in the last five years we spent half of
our money on patient aid on on all cases
what we call old cases and the other
half on current cases now if we don't
get this 20 million dollars we simply
can't take care of those patients and
that would be a catastrophe because that
would mean that patients that were
cheered for might eliminate some of
those crippling effects which they may
not eliminate if we can't care for them
you still feel so that there we are on
the verge of victory over this dread
disease I don't have any doubt about it
I I think we're very hopeful that this
assault vaccine will prove to be
effective and that if it does of course
that'll be the answer for that we will
still have a tremendous load of back
cases that will have to take care of and
we'll have refinements to make in the
vaccine but unless the immunology of
polio is entirely different from every
other disease we feel very encouraged
about the success of this vaccine thank
you very much iconica coming here
tonight the opinions expressed on the
lawn team Chronos cope were those of the
speakers the editorial board for this
edition of the lawn gene chrono scope
was Larry lesser and Ned calmar our
distinguished guest was basil O'Connor
president of the National Foundation for
infantile paralysis